you know we lost many beloved luminaries
this year and it's time now to honor and
remember the people
who made an indelible mark on those of
us who watch and work in television
this year's emmy awards paid tribute to
the many
actors actresses and tv creators who
died over the last year
with a touching in memoriam segment
[Music]
near the end of sunday's live ceremony
two-time grammy winner her saying a
rendition of nothing compares to you
over a video montage of those past
including regis philbin who died at the
age of 88
in july i want people to
enjoy what i do and and understand what
i'm doing
is for their enjoyment and
that's all i can ask for naya rivera who
died in a boating accident in july
and chadwick boseman who lost his
four-year battle with cancer at the age
of 43
in august purpose crosses disciplines
purpose is an essential element of you
it is the reason you are on the planet
at this particular time in history
the struggles along the way are only
meant
to shape you for your purpose
[Music]
the heartfelt tribute honored several
emmy winners and
nominees including diana rigg
carl reiner fred willard jerry stiller
and james lipton just to name a few of
course the emmys acknowledged that not
every celebrity who died this year would
be
featured in their tribute citing time
constraints
and one celeb who was noticeably missing
was kelly preston
who died in july at the age of 57 after
a two-year battle with breast cancer
also missing kobe bryant who died in
january in a helicopter crash
and nick cordero who died from
coronavirus complications in july
but before her took the stage the
night's host
jimmy kimmel paid respect to supreme
court justice
ruth bader ginsburg who died on friday
on friday we lost a great american
ruth bader ginsburg was a compassionate
and tireless champion
of equality and justice who said her
legacy
was to make life a little better for
people less fortunate than she
sounds like pretty good words to live by
to me